the jurgen experience the mat the amount
of backlash and [ __ ] i got when i
started and had a show out was
brutal it was brutal i didn't know you
then
i met you at the laugh factory i
remember i met you at the lab factory i
had already been kicked out of the
comedy store and that was it was during
my time where i was doing other clubs
so it was somewhere around like
2007-ish or something like that upstairs
i met you so i don't remember where i
met you
but i'm like you're in the corner crying
um yeah it's so weird to think that
because i was at the comedy store when
you were not and you were still such a
big presence there in a way that it's
because ari was there you know it just
was i don't know i felt like i knew you
maybe before i knew yeah
that was a weird time it was a weird
time for you too because like there was
a lot of people hating on you because
your show because it was so big like you
had these giant billboards and your face
was everywhere
you know that's just one of those things
where
that [ __ ] green envy monster pops out
of people and they get so mad but it's
also i'm a comic i know what you're
making fun of if there was a show called
you know um you know
rita with some girl holding a beach ball
like like being sassy i would make fun
of it too it was like you know i was
young and and you know it's like as a
comedian you get an offer like that how
old were you when you got uh whitney 27
27 damn that's crazy you have your own
show at 27.
and i wanted to hire all my friends i
fought really hard even though i had no
power you know i wrote the part for
crystalia you know and i said i don't
want to do this without him not that i
even had any of that power at the time
you know of course they want to cast
like these actors that have been on nine
shows and that have been on a bunch of
failed shows you're like why do i want
someone that's the amer or people have
voted they don't want to
see was it that you started doing
stand-up
2004
so you were only doing stand-up for a
short period of time
how many years before you got your show
six that's wild
that's wild wild
i was doing the roast i was a writer for
the roasts
and then i was on the roasts and i
comedy central did not i never got
premium blend or i never got gotham
i never got
new faces in montreal which really quick
just a joke that you might appreciate
that i wrote for joan rivers at the joan
rivers roast but didn't tell this is
kind of an inside comedy thing
joan rivers has had so much work done on
her face every year she books montreal
new faces
and
so then i did the joan rivers roast and
i did so well that comedy central
offered me
a half hour and then i just was like i
wanted to do one to do an hour because
you know they said no to me so many
times right as soon as i had leverage i
just was like
right use it [ __ ] this yeah because also
then on when when comedians complain
about their clips being you know broken
up on instagram or their stand-up being
broken up i always try to go like
remember when we were in comedy central
and they would break up our specials
seven minutes
and then a four-minute commercial and
then five minutes
they would just arbitrarily break it up
anywhere
and you only actually had 42 minutes to
actually do stand up yeah and your set
was [ __ ] up because like sometimes
those bits would continue after the
commercial break and people would forget
what the [ __ ] premise is and if
people were just tuning in they had no
idea they didn't give a [ __ ] they just
shoved those commercials in there i
remember my it's like adam and eve and
you're like cool like i remember i used
to my second comedy central special i
remember trying to time it
seven minutes punchline killer as and do
like three mini sets with little closers
instead of one big set yeah because of
the way they would cut it up to be 27
and have your own show is so crazy crazy
it's so
it's so like
so much pressure that must have been
like really overwhelming and weird well
because i think at that point you think
more is more in terms of press publicity
that kind of stuff but keep doing it do
it all but it's also i didn't realize
how um
you know it's interesting the way that
you know whether it's our business or
just people in general they look at
comedians as kind of these children that
need to be babysat instead of these
mature adults that have gone all around
the country and you know comported
ourselves actually we act like silly
gooses sometimes but we really have our
[ __ ] together it's what we do is not
easy so
going in and and when they were making
the billboards and stuff i was like you
guys this is this looks like a cheesy
sitcom from the this looks like uh
veronica's closet like this looks like a
fran drescher show from the 80s it was
like because it was multicam it was like
purple font and i don't know what i was
doing they do those photo shoots with
you and they're like you know make this
face like do this and i'm like oh man i
was like painted as like the finger
wagging like annoying girlfriend i don't
know but the show was like a role
reversal it was about me someone who had
come from three divorces and was
actually commitment phobic but in love
with someone and trying to figure out
how to like you know like someone who's
kind of feral trying to be domesticated
to be in a normal relationship yeah you
know and it was people loved it they
couldn't get past the multi-cam of it um
and which is weird because i feel like
multicam is so respected in one
in one way cheers and well explain what
to people what that means it means you
did it in front of a live audience sure
like when you shoot show in front of
live studio audience roseanne so who
couldn't get passion what do you mean
they couldn't get past that i think
people would just were so mad that i
like existed that they couldn't it was
like well that's a laugh track they were
mad that you existed
maybe
that's interesting so it's just who are
these people i don't know like critics
or other comics like what do you i don't
know it was i think i also it was a
multi i did two multicams that year
shows in front of a live studio audience
uh the whitney show and then two broke
girls two brook girls was on cbs it was
beloved and ended up going for six
seasons that was a show that had other
multicams two and a half men
big bang theory um mike and molly so
that was so the network was already sort
of set up for that and anyone watching
that network is already
queens yeah i followed the office and
community on oh i see so they were used
to single cam things being shot kind of
like a movie i think the inside cool
kids club was like what's this like i
got news for you that club sucks
and those people that are in that club
are all [ __ ]
the inside cool kid club
those are [ __ ] pretending to not be
[ __ ] well you know what they're
they're douche bags pretending to be
kind and considerate and the irony is
like they all it's a lot it's a lot of
harvard guys
it's like harvard lampoon guys well some
of the best writers yeah i've met a lot
of great writers from harvard it's kind
of amazing how many good like a lot of
the guys from news radio where we're
harvard guys oh interesting that lampoon
thing right there you know really smart
guys who
became
the you know that that you got sort of
ushered into this group and it was a
great way to like use that intellect and
that love of comedy and comedy writing
and it was already like a clearly
established path you know like paul sims
had come through there and all these
different
and when they came through it's like
there was other ones that had already
paved the path it was like oh i'll just
go on to write for sitcoms right and
then i you know hey this guy's really
funny we'll hire him he was also in you
know the lampoon but you're not better
than me because he went to harvard we're
both telling dick jokes
we're both doing dick jokes here guys
you know i mean that that is always a
part of harvard right a part of ivy
league education is that you know some
people are going to feel like they're
elite right which is fine if you're
doing elite work but there's a lot of
people that we're just not
you know and but they had the attitude